welcome everybody for this
second day of this very nice workshop
so it's my pleasure to introduce the
first speaker of this afternoon yunnan
yang
who is going to talk about
optimal transport for learning chaotic
dynamics via invariant measures so thank
you yes thank you very much for the
introduction and thank you very much for
the invitation for me being here as has
been more than two months i think it
just goes so fast i kind of believe it's
already two months here so today i got
this chance to present something i
worked on very recently with my
collaborators
lavon nebraskan elisa negrini robert
martin and maja parsha
so i have a short story to tell so i i
never know of the anya with them in
person so we started the collaboration
through zoom and so far till today i
only know their 2d projections
so but it kind of worked eventually so
we started it from this ab ham workshop
last year about april uh that's when
pandemic just happened
and then thanks to adam oberman who
brought us together and say if you want
to work on something but he uh
disappeared in the middle so we continue
to work on something and one year later
we have this work
and it's also
it's very interesting um experience
so
uh so today i'm mainly talk about one of
the papers uh and you can find the print
print online uh is on archive
so uh before i continue to the details i
want to introduce the notion of lagrange
and orlarian maybe not be the most
accurate way of using the two objectives
but whenever i say lagrangian
perspective i mean i'm in the particle
perspective this is the picture from
this very famous book transport
phenomenon so if we are tracing with the
particles then i'm going with the
particle like the particle changes with
the time and it's the trajectory and i
use
and i use this particle trajectory to
describe what is the fluid uh what the
properties physical phenomena etc
and if i'm using the word ellarian which
means i'm actually in the probability
distribution perspective i mean in the
load part
well you as an observer we are fixed at
xyz location and we just look at how
many
uh was the property of the fluid was the
density that flowing around and was the
momentum so we are fixed so that's what
i mean uh being a alluring perspective
i find a lot of the things we uh
deal with especially in computational
fluid dynamics and also solid mechanics
you have this uh
opportunity to interchange between these
two most of the time about one physical
phenomenon you can either use the
particle perspective describe it or you
can use eulerian perspective to describe
it and that give us a lot of flexibility
in especially in dealing with universe
problems and another similar situation
occur actually in the waves you can
characterize waves by wave equation but
you can also characterize waves by the
hammerhead equation in the frequency
domain so those interchanges was also
very beneficial in that aspect
so today i'm going to change from
lagrangian to alaria and to then some
stability and the well posing of solving
the universe problem
okay
so first of all i want to emphasize that
uh we are dealing with chaotic dynamic
systems and whenever you use the word
chaotic you are already in a
deterministic setting and the reason it
is chaotic is what is happening locally
doesn't really tell you what's happening
a long time uh a very long time later
so here what you see is a very famous
lauren 63 model
with only three parameters but this
three parameters sigma rule and beta has
their own physical meanings and a very
simple setup for the universe problem is
i observe time trajectories from this
ode system in terms of time t zero all
the way to tn and the question is will
you be able to tell what is the sigma
rho and the beta so such questions are
very relevant especially one of our
collaborator was at air force national
library uh laboratories so for example
if you want to create a digital tune of
some realistic aerospace modeling you
always have to do model collaboration to
find the best parameters so there's
there is a patient background why people
are interested in such phenomena and
most of the time you observe trajectory
data
okay
so
while the the previous one is the lorenz
63 uh model proposed in 1963 so that
there you have three parameters but
nowadays you can have more like the ones
the way to promptumize your model
because what you don't know is entirely
the right hand side is entirely the
lagrangian velocity so
if you know a lot of the physics right
like lawrence you know a lot of physics
you can compromise it by sigma beta but
if you don't know it it's also fine so
there's some literature uh like for
example if you compromise your entire
right hand side by polynomials global
polynomials
then you can find the basis coefficient
and that's give rest of the work cindy
in pnas
from the uw group uh up there and also
there's another group that i know
schaefer and the word so if you can
think you can parametrize the right hand
side as a linear
uh combination of your polynomials and
try to find the basis coefficients and
that become a sparse linear algebra
problem
or you can use other basis function
which i just learned from tang uh
in the previous seminar talk it can be
piecewise polynomial that's also give
you a lot more freedom and again you can
learn the coefficient and other basis
function for all kind of chebyshev
polynomial larger under polynomials is
also free to choose
and also very recently there's a lot of
literature in compromising your anterior
hand side
velocity of neural networks based on
probably a very good approximation
theory from neural networks that's even
more references
so no matter how you promptumize it
physically or polynomial or basis or
some other way to functionalize it in
the end you have to find the
coefficients you need to find the uh the
weights in the neural network case or
the coefficient in the polynomial case
and i will denote this entire
coefficient to be theta
so if you we are sticking with this
lagrangian perspective of the problem so
what is our data our data will be just
the time trajectories i uh observed in
the time domain okay and the universe
problem will be
let me just work with this time
trajectories and try to find what is the
coefficient no matter the physical or
they are just polynomial basis or their
neural network rates so that's that's
the framework and that's actually a lot
of the works have been based upon
this is
the mainstream way of doing that
so this is a very nice way to do and a
very standard way to do universal in
this case except
there's a actual level of difficulty
come from chaotic systems
which is the famous butterfly effect
so i have two trajectories
one starts with 10 10 10 it's a spatial
location and another one starting with
10.001
10 10 as a spatial location and i run it
so at the beginning since it is such an
absolute change i don't see any
difference
in the first ten thousand time steps but
afterwards you can see these two
trajectories deviate from each other
ginormously
and the test means when i no longer
assess is actually the chaotic behavior
that are locally propagation give you a
really really bad deviation in a long
time
uh uh
uh process
and unfortunately when you observe the
data you see this huge difference but
this huge difference has nothing to do
with a wrong parameter or not this huge
difference just comes from the chaotic
behavior of the dynamical system you are
working with and in numerous common
language for us that's your postness
okay
and also on top of that this is just
chaotic by definition code system but on
top of that if you have
intrinsic noise which means when you
were modeling the dynamical system right
hand side there's a little bit noise in
it
or there's extreme signals which means
you already measure the dynamic of the
trajectory but just when you do the
measurement there's a little bit
perturbation when you're recording it
then you also get entirely different
trajectories so on the right hand side
in this picture i show these three
situations no noise versus intrinsic
noise versus extrinsic noise and the
such noise as you can imagine they
accumulate
thanks to this is a
chaotic system
so such difficulties make it very uh
intractable in the sense that you can't
really you may not be able to trust your
reconstructed parameter because it could
really
just come from this could just come from
epsilon in the initial condition and in
realistic situation you never get a
solid hold of the initial condition
so such difficulties motivate us to have
an alternative way of solving that
another idea
is to look at what they share in common
and to explore the stable information
among those unstable word chaotic time
trajectories
so in this paper we have we consider
three attractors uh
lauren's chen and the restless they all
can be characterized as a chaotic
systems
so next is the idea
so although they are chaotic in terms of
very sensitive to the initial condition
or very sensitive to the noise but there
are some well-defined statistical
properties
so first of all if you give me a long
time trajectory i can define uh
so-called occupation manager so what is
the occupation measure in terms of
numerical aspect it is binning it is a
histogram
if you give me a long time trajectory
and i just divide this domain into boxes
and the count how many times this
trajectory goes through that box and if
it goes through once then i count it at
one and then divided by t which is
equivalent to divided by the total
number of steps so if you give me a time
charge i will be able to go to
occupation manager and the is of course
depends on how discretized and how you
define the histogram um
bin right but this one is easy to obtain
so once we have this occupation measure
and the nice thing is this is highly
related to the sinaiju buoyant measure
called rcib measure in the context of
dynamical system
which means if you run the time
trajectory long enough as t going to
infinity
then your occupation measure will
converge to the physical measure mu star
and then this is what we can refer to as
the physical miter with inventories or
srb imaging
and then this environment by its
definition it's no longer sensitive to
the initial condition but just by its
definition it's environment
and also that's something we can obtain
both from the trajectories
so the idea is instead of working with
the long time trajectory and working
just twist the time and the particles we
just work with the measure which is
easily can be transformed from my
long-term trajectory
okay now now we have a data that is much
more robust to noise as you can see in
this case
so the first uh row is the time is
accumulation binding process occupation
measure with no noise while the second
row is this intrinsic noise and the last
row is transition wise although they
have slightly difference but if you
observe the geometric features they have
very similar property and if i use
objective function that's kind of robust
to such minor differences i will get a
pretty good universe problem
reconstruction
so that's true
is your physical measure is it literally
the srp measure or is it something
slightly different i think as physical
manager is our savvy measure it depends
i think at least the reference we refer
to as they call them the same thing yeah
well what we can always numerically get
i think it's going to be our
approximation to that rtb measure so
that's why i refer to this as occupation
manager because this is what i obtained
by bending my trajectory
so now we have a more reliable a more
stable data
con
from the trajectory next is how can i
get a model because inverse problem you
know the way we solve it is you have a
guess for the parameter
you you see the data and you compare
with the ground with the reference and
you see ah they are not the same let me
change the parameter again so we have to
reduce this process
if not dozens or hundreds of the times
clearly if i'm keeping i keep running
long time trajectory and binning it it's
going to be very expensive for each
evaluation that's why i also need a new
model i cannot just keep running the
temp uh dynamical system and
obtaining that
the very nice connection again by the
definition of the physical matter or by
the definition of the uh major this is
from a paper by lesson in 2002
so this is the definition for
environment major mu star
okay
so f is the test function and it can be
any smooth test function here which was
c infinity
but now if i choose f to be related to
my velocity v
and i plug into the same equation that
we have on the top
we have
uh by the change of variable and also
some integration you actually get this
integration in the end has to be zero
so
again fee is that fee here is a test
function and the fact that this equal to
0 for any test function c
telling me my environment is exactly a
stationary
distributional solution
to the continuity equation that we have
seen many times in the past two days
so this gives me approximately a new
model
right because if there's a connection
this is the same v the right hand side
of the dynamical system but now instead
of running the time trajectory for two
million time steps i can just try to
find the environment the stationary
distribution was digital solution to
this continuity equation then i can get
an approximation to my uh numerical
manager and the universe problem says me
evaluating the forward map and i have a
much faster way to evaluating it rather
than each time i have a guess for theta
i run it like millions of time steps
so now it also give us a very nice uh
model and so we so far we have changed
the data from trajectory to environment
occupation manager and we also have a
model
that is the continue equation the steady
state solution
rather than the p the ode itself
so just to summarize the idea from
lagrangian to lrm our starting point was
to find the parameter in the dynamical
system
and the intermediate step is to change
we are observed the data into our
occupation manager
and in order to model that we realize
there is a connection to the steady or
stationary distributional solution of
the continuity equation and on the right
hand side what you are seeing it is the
largest system after running long enough
so they convert to this attractor which
is a two-dimensional manifold in this uh
three-dimensional space
so now we have uh this model so again to
to see that our uh proposal was instead
of solving the universe problem as an
ode based
problem uh ode constraint optimization
we saw it as a pd constraint
optimization because now my forward
problem becomes give me a parameter i
solve the continuity equation i get the
solution and then i compare with the
truth to choose reference data
and then the universe problem is also
based on the continuum and once we are
in the pde constraint optimization
regime there's actually a lot of
literature especially from europe that
uh about how to do that how to compute
the gradient how to analyze all the
properties and optimization algorithms
and that's also what i did for my phd so
that's a part of a familiar ground
okay
so now after this all changes in the
data and also the change from the model
now we are dealing as literally a pde
constraint optimization and the problem
is similar to something we saw yesterday
if you are dealing with neural network
you want to find this
and the data as i mentioned earlier can
be your neural network weights or can be
a coefficient for polynomials or can be
low beta sigma the physical parameter
well rho star is the occupation measure
you observe from the time trajectories
so we need binning the good news is on
you only need beanie once you only need
to do this histogram for your
observed reference data
okay while the model is the steady state
solution to the continuity equation at
this particular parameter theta
so this problem really come
become like a standard
pde constraint optimization while d is
chosen as a proper matrix that can
capture the essential differences
between my reference distribution or
measurement major rho star versus my
synthetic
rho theta that come from this continuity
equation so for example
a very good choice of d will be the
vaccine metric and here we use the
quadratic ratio step metric
so the
the reason under the goal here is
the forward problem have changed
dynamical system to pde the data has
changed trajectory to occupation manager
but the parameter never get changed
it's still this velocity
so the parameter is still embedded in my
od in my pd model so that's the next
thing that's the connection of these two
different frameworks and the motivation
of doing this change is that now you are
more stable at least what i mentioned
earlier initial condition influence is
down noise is also more robust and also
not to mention we are using the various
metrics to compare
okay
so like so in terms of how to solve the
forward model i'm just going to comment
a little bit
so the forum now now becomes solving the
continu stationary distribution to the
continuity equation
and uh so here we use first order
average scheme that you saw yesterday
from diaz antonio's talk
okay and also as i mentioned yesterday
that final volume method the way that
you are solving it by final volume you
are already in a weak regime because
final volume is integration in each
spatial cell so it is already a weak
solution to the original pde so that's
fixed perfect that the original model is
also a distributional solution so we
discretize it still as is time dependent
but once you
discretized by admin scheme you actually
obtain a very nice
markov matrix that's the beauty of
advanced scheme it allows you to have a
conservation of mass and a positivity
preserving and in terms of linear
algebra it means you have a markov
matrix
well the problem becomes how can i find
the rho such that i'm rho equal to rho
so it also becomes eigenvalue
eigenvector problem but the good news is
you already know the eigenvalue the
eigenvalue has to be one so
the rest is sparse linear algebra so
although it give us a
how to say a markov matrix so we
regularized a little bit by this
well-known pagerank google's page rank
trick which is called teleportation so
we regularize the original molecule
matrix as a linear combination between
uh this one epsilon of the original one
versus epsilon of this new one this new
one is
just
one entry involved in every component
but by this regularization m epsilon's
theta will have strictly positive
entries and based on the power and
forbidden theorem you're guaranteed to
have a unique solution so that's in
terms of numerics that give me unique
eigenvector and it does also give me a
better condition number which means i
can find the solution yeah much faster
speed
and once we do the regularization the
solution can be found by sparse linear
solver and i want to comment you know
three-dimensional uh
case this step of funding the station's
distribution range from 8 seconds to 20
seconds based on your mesh so this is
nothing compared to running time
trajectory for
2 million steps and do the binding so
it's a much much faster way of obtaining
a surrogate model
okay
so next i want to comment a little bit
the choice of the vaccine distance to
compare the reference
calculation measure and my synthetic
stationary distribution and here we use
the vectors and distance and that
there's two reasons i want to use rashes
and distance and that is routed to what
i did in my phd
so one thing which is also part of the
program's name the virtual symmetric
really captures the geometric
information and when we are dealing with
such physical problems like wavy
equation based on the universal bond
work this base the universe problem
there is the intrinsic geometric change
embedded in your forward model and if
you use vectors and distance you can
capture for example things like
translational dilation and it's convex
in terms of those simple changes and if
my model dependence from theta to rho
it's also such genetics then this is a
perfect choice and this is something we
have investigated a lot in maybe
equation-based universe problems
so i i don't have time to address that
but just to show you visually the
fundamental difference
i have two ways and that uh i want to
infer what's going on underneath the
ground right i only can do this matching
between the synthetic data and the
reference data to find what's going on
under the ground
and that is optimized pde constraint
optimization and on the left hand side
you saw by doing using least square
non-linearly square method these are
also known as objective function and we
cannot reconstruct you can see the
residual rarely decreased after a while
that's
technically our local minimum
while the various and distance they
start with the same initial we will be
able to diminish a lot of the data
residual and in the end reconstruct my
minus model so this is because we were
dealing the wave under the change
between the wave time domain data and
the velocity
is most likely translational dilation so
that was a very um perfect use of the
washer stem
metric in terms of its properties and
now there's a lot of people doing things
like this
um yeah from cause and france and china
etc
so one thing is the geometric feature
that is really nice
like to capture my fundamental inverse
problems uh continue dependence between
theta and the rho another thing which oh
sorry before i go into another thing i
want to show you in this
chaotic dynamical system reconstruction
you also have a translational dilation
so the right one is the initial dynamics
the blue one is reconstructive or the
green one is the brown shoes so you can
see changing from the initial to the
truth in three-dimensional you have to
stretch you have to do a translation and
that's another thing that i think
russian distance will be perfectly for
and the second reason why we like
smashes and distance in this situation
is is insensitive noise and there are
two lines of work i have some so far
once from felix uh philadelph and the
villani in the telegram paper they found
the connection between value two and h
minus one semi norm and the reason the
remy prairie
has a paper uh also uh proving the
equivalence between various and distant
and h1 so seminar so what is hm minus
one semi norm it is a weak norm and it
is insensitive to noise so that's why in
this situation when i have very noisy
data
as my reference i will still be able to
reconstruct my music model
because of actual distance doesn't see
this noise
because again it is a weak norm
and
and also based on the fact that we
transport because we transport and we
don't have to transfer much to cancel
the noise that's why we don't see it
so these are two main reasons why we use
washers and distance
and
so next is uh now we have the model we
have the data we have objective function
in terms of doing pde constraint
optimization we need to differentiate we
need to be able to get the gradient
so we want to comment a little bit of
differentiation of the vector symmetry
and that's the main part of contribution
from lavon in this paper
so now when we talk about the
differentiability it's not
differentiability with respect to yo
which is probably the case that many
there's a lot of classical results like
how what when when you can differentiate
vectors and distance we can find all in
all the books but here since i don't
really care about the row what i fully
care about what i really want to find is
theta so i care about the
differentiability of the vectors and
distance with respect to theta and
there's actually some difference between
these two
so we again i just repeat it with the
formula and we want to differentiate
with respect to theta and the question
is when f is differentiable when can i
carry out the derivatives and that's i
think it's quite a relevant problem when
that no matter you are doing neural
network training or anything you are
using russian sentencing as a data
matching term you probably will
encounter such a problem
or such a question
uh but this formula is continually
showing up in all the papers that we
can't ever find right we this is a
counteracting potential between row and
the rho star and then this is the state
has row it looks like a perfect chain
rule right we see this a lot of the time
but we didn't find a lot of analysis but
i think when people tear out the changes
they already assume both exist
and a nice
we should be able to do it
um
okay
so it depends on how you are going to
carry out the chain rule in the vertices
and distance you can carry out the
channel in the flat matrix space and
that's exactly you this right term gives
you the counter argument potential and
then you'll have this data zero so this
could be one potential way how you how
one reach this formula eventually
or
we can do the chain rule in the vector
vaccine matrix in the tangent space
and in that case there is also a chain
rule like it's just the derivative in
the rashes and tangent space before you
drag it down to the flat space
okay so uh you then carry out you you
get exactly the same formula so if they
all exist it doesn't matter which chain
you carry out
however this is based on the fact that
they all exist
the question is if neither
the contaminant potential exists nor
this this data this term which is the
lowest um
as a curve of theta uh whether the
derivative exists even not necessary
neither of them exists then neither of
the channels will work which means you
may probably you cannot use this formula
okay so that's what we will puzzle a
little bit and try to see what was the
connection with the condition we can
actually use this formula
and the result uh it's actually a little
more general than what we thought
so here is an example where neither of
them exist
so first of all is the counter argument
potential if we forget about theta i
just think this is the problem between
rho and the rho star
then in september in his uh chapter
seven there's like a page that is about
this discussion and in order for
that means counteraverage potential
should be um it's never unique but it
should be unique up to constant on this
entire domain
but in this case it's not unique up to a
global constant because in the middle
you can be anything so in this
particular case the uh is now
the kind of work that they wrote
dw20 doesn't exist
okay
in the second case which is
uh dod theta so in the rajasthan case if
we can replace theta by t for example in
order to make this thing differentiable
you'll need to be absolutely continuous
with respect to theta but this example
is not absolutely continuous with
respect to sata that's another reason
why it doesn't exist if theta is if you
represented by t for example okay so
this two is a counter example where you
cannot this very simple case is example
you cannot use it
um
okay so we actually
so what's going on is it's uh
i just want to say the answer first so
although if you want to carry out from
the chain rule
it doesn't exist but by our result
this case is actually differentiable
with respect to theta it's just that you
cannot justify it's just that you cannot
justify by change
is it still differentiable with respect
to satan
is except the one theta equal to zero so
it's just you cannot justify by theta so
this is something
i would say a little bit contribution
from our work so similar setups like
about differentiability you can find a
lot in non-parametric setting which
means there's no theta it's just between
you and the row star but new effects
appear in the parametric regime
especially if you don't want to
call the chain rule so this is our
result
so if the mapping from theta to your
theta to row of zeta is nice which
satisfy some assumption we have in the
paper
and then in order for you to use it
as long as the counterweight potential
is constant you're almost everywhere
rather than almost everywhere then you
will be able where it's okay to use this
formula because it still got too
differentiable
so i want to comment that this is
actually different from what somebody uh
sometime radio uh had in the paper uh in
the book in section chapter 7.2
in he particularly has a paragraph
saying if there's no theta
you have to have the control potential
to be constant or everywhere rather than
rule everywhere so in without data this
is not enough but this data in there and
with this map is nice actually this is
actually good enough
uh and then the next question is when
can i justify when will i be sure that
c2 minus v1 will be constant your almost
error which means they can be constant
when they can be different when yo is
now supported where visual is zero
so we give a sufficient condition when
you can guarantee that
under the sufficient condition is called
linked
so the question is how can you guarantee
that so
the sufficient condition is
some definition of linked so i think
this is really hard to describe so it's
better to have an example
so let's say your domain
your role is not really connected so you
have parts that the definition or is
absolutely zero so the support is
disconnected
but
uh if the mapping or the image under the
transfer plan
are also disconnect the closure of the
mapping is disconnected then this is
what we call not linked
but if the closure of the corresponding
mapping are connected in the closure
sense they don't have to be connected
but it's connected in a closure sense
then we call this as linked
so in our result we show a slot
your optimal plan is like this situation
as on this map are linked
then
uh it will have a v2 minus v1 constantly
almost everywhere so then the then this
is the theorem so if it's mutually
linked
yeah the code and then v2 minus v1 is
constantly almost ever and if you refer
to previous clearly that means it has
got a differentiable which means you are
safe to
use this formula in terms of
differentiation with respect to theta so
in the end it turns out to be a lot more
general
rather than just chain rule by itself so
that's also a good news
so finally we give an example
uh here
so this is a particular example we
created
yo depend on sata
so i want to comment that your theta is
not absolutely continuous
so that's actually where one of the
changes will fail
and then this is not go to
differentiable
because of the support
for you is disconnected okay so the
other channel will also fail
however
this is total differentiable
so this is saying that you don't have to
call it from channel you can just
directly doing it as a function of theta
god doesn't have to go to a function of
rule another
a function of sata afterwards
okay
so now let's uh i think if the case this
assumption satisfy we should be safe to
do a derivative we have a gradient and
finally back to the inverse problem
framework we need to do it iteratively
to get the parameter and thanks to the
so-called adjoint state method which i'm
um it's a very powerful method in the
community of pde constraint optimization
no matter you were using it for optimal
control or universe problems this will
give you a way to deal with large scale
universe problem because you only need
these four steps and you only need to
solve two pdes to some extent to get a
gradient of hundreds millions uh so yeah
no matter how many parameters you have
so at each edition
at each iteration we first solved for
the steady state and this is based on
the markov matrix that i mentioned
earlier so that's sparse linear algebra
eight to twenty seconds based on your
second i'm using rushes and distance so
i would like to get the controllable
potential since that is an important
component for me to compute the gradient
so once i get the control potential i
plug in into this adjoining equation
which is formally a i joint of the
linearization of the forward problem
and i get something called lambda and i
join equation normally it's very
non-physical but the reason you have
either an equation purely because you
want to do gradient descent
okay and finally this yo l and the
lambda l
this is your gradient
based on the formula that we just showed
so this is our gradient and then uh
sorry this entire part is our gradient
and then you can do gradient descent or
even more advanced version non-linear
conjugate gradient or lbfgs and this is
the one iteration and we do it again and
again until we find the parameters
okay
uh yeah i want to comment since this is
like a few seconds then this is also a
few seconds so
uh vargas and this is three dimensional
right nowadays is not too bad so this
actually doesn't take a lot of the time
if your discrimination is not too fine
it's still trackable
uh so let's look at the numerical
examples first is the synthetic case in
the case in the sense that i get my rho
star
actually fakely from the continuity
equation so in universe problem we call
this inverse crime because the data is
from the same silver the server that you
obtain the forward solution so the in
this synthetic or inverse crime
situation there's no modeling error
because you use the same model to
generate their data so we can find the
sigma rule beta just
found that it's correctly very very fast
and there is a multi-parameter
phenomenon and is common in inverse
problem if we want to find the parameter
three different parameters
simultaneously they interact with each
other because each time the gradient is
by assuming the other one is correct so
when you do them simultaneously they may
not really go into the direction that
help you to go down so one way to deal
with that is to do the so-called
coordinate decent so one iteration you
only do one of them try to avoid the
potential
interaction of each other
okay
so this is the synthetic case and the
next case is the realistic case in the
sense my real style really comes from
the occupation manager it comes from the
dynamical system and in this case you
can see we no longer can reduce the
vectors and distance to absolute zero
and if i reduce my vertices and distance
to absolute zero i'm overfitting
terribly
so
so that's why uh you can see the decent
no longer which is good maybe i did it
on purpose i don't want it to be
absolute zero
and also you can see some overfitting
phenomenon by looking at the model
parameters error especially for beta it
goes down to zero first so it was at the
truth but because of the overfitting in
terms of the modeling error it go up
again and a similar thing you can see
here it's go down and it doesn't go up
again so that's because there's still
some modern error between my occupation
measure accumulated from the dynamical
system
versus the continuous equation steady
state solution so that's something i
definitely well most of the time i think
it's a numerical error due to the first
order of finite volume method that a lot
of people in the numerical analysis
community will laugh at me
but although we didn't get absolutely
perfect parameter we can just try to see
the reconstruct parameter the
reconstructed recontrol dynamics the
real contracted dynamics match uh in
shape or in the global feature like the
original uh the the blue one another
green one are pretty good
so that's the that's the the parameters
so they were not absolutely the correct
so you can see correct is this 10 28 8
over 3
very classical set of parameters but
what we reconstruct is not absolutely
like that value
so this is the three parameter case so
you may want to ask me why i
spent so much effort like doing various
and decent continuous equations in the
end just from the three single scalers
of course the ultimate goal is now just
to find three single scalers and that's
what we actually did after this paper
and this is john work with jonah but
vinnie greenhouse which is who is a
first-year graduate student at cornell
so we want to
test whether the framework can actually
work with variable coefficient and the
first scenario we work with is just to
simply change the logarithm system
from a constant coefficient to a
variable coefficient
then now after this quantization sigma
is no longer a scalar sigma is based on
online mesh in three dimensional that's
easily almost like a million of them
rather than three so now the the stress
is high so i want to see if the
framework can still reconstruct
sigmarion beta but more importantly not
about sigma run the beta i really want
to see if it can reconstruct the
dynamics because i'm clearly over
functionalizing my right hand side
laurence's tell me three parameters
enough and now i'm
making it this large
okay and again i want to comment due to
the beauty of hydraulic method
the complexity of computer gradient is
exactly the same as before you didn't
waste any more from each time so solving
this side of the problem versus the
earlier problem is exactly the same
computation plus some discretization of
the storage of the mesh
so this is actually the reconstructed
sigma u and the beta since they are
three dimensional objects so i'm just
showing their two-dimensional projection
in this case each of them is a function
of cd
so
the ground truth is of course
absolutely a constant but what's
interesting is we didn't reconstruct a
constant and moreover would we get
reconstructed what's really different
from the original it's highly correlated
with where your attractor was located so
that's something very interesting and
also
in universe problem we have a saying
when there's no data then there's no
parameter so if my data which my
inverted measure
didn't exist in that area then my
reconstruction in this area may not be
reliable
unless you have some prayer knowledge
that for example you think is
a polynomial expansion etcetera
otherwise you basically cannot trust
them
okay so this is the parameter which is
non-constant but the dynamics look good
so although we are not uh using this so
this is the initial the the black one is
the initial very
initial parameter starting point
but the final reconstruction overlapped
with the true dynamics
and another thing we were doing very
recently is the fact that to be a little
bit more advanced rather than just
creating a fake lawrence is to
try to reconstruct the chain system
while the entire right hand side is
parametrized as a function of x y z so
we have three parts so it's a vector
field so becomes theta one theta two and
the theta three and then again after
this credit addition on your mesh there
will be thousands of variables but
it doesn't really matter too much it's
the same complexity as you are solving
this three parameter universe problem
due to either method
so this is uh it's our very colors mesh
the first
column is the initial with the wrong
parameter while the middle is the final
reconstruction and the right hand side
is the target distribution or in this 3d
projection
so that's where i can observe my
environment for example
and then this is the reconstruction
change this is the change between the
initial to the final uh in terms of my
parameters in the projection
so again i want to emphasize just how
much they coincide with each other in
terms of where you see there will be a
parameter update
and this is again due to the fact that
if you don't have data
in those area
you really don't know the velocity in
those areas unless you have
actual prior knowledge about what's
going on there so if because the way we
uh characterize it or in terms of finite
volume discrimination is basically
piecewise constant for solder so there's
no actual assumption in what's going on
globally and that's why when we see the
update there's no update in this part at
all because there's no data
and finally we can see the dynamics like
converging so this is the initial
and the the red one is the true dynamics
and then there's the final uh like the
blue and the red
so we are still working in terms of this
direction
so finally i think we are perfect on
time i would like to draw a summary so
the entire idea was
built upon the fact that
in this regime we're in dealing with
dynamics we have these two connections
the
the lagrangian and the interchanges
between each other actually can help us
a lot so i have a separate work in both
my equation i was exactly doing the
other way around i was turning both my
equation into particles that is relevant
to lagrangian but this this this work is
lagrangiano lauren
and the nice thing is i use some of my
old training in uh final volume medicine
and the computational it dynamic
discredition that give me a very
efficient way to evaluate the forward
problem because it's become markov's
matrix i'm really equal to rho a sparse
linear algebra and also because we are
using finite volume discrimination
the m is three tri-diagonal matrices
added together so it's really really
sparse so that's also contribute to fact
that we can solve it fast
optimal transport and why i like it
because the fact that it can capture the
underlying geometric change induced by
this
map and the reason we use the address
state method is unlike generated models
or many other models a lot of models in
od or pde is implicit
because exactly od and a pde most of the
time you don't have experience
dependence on its initial condition or
on its boundary condition it's all given
to you as a ode which is implicit
formulation but hydro statements will
help you to get the gradient for an
implicit constraint and finally
multiparameter is always a hard problem
in universal problem and there's four
future directions if a numerical analyst
i would like to improve my final volume
solver when i is force older so that
will be better and also right now i'm
using continuity equation to approximate
the occupation measurable environment i
accumulate
there better way to do it or
more adding some component to make it
more realistic as you saw earlier there
was some modeling error and i want to
reduce that and this is also related to
the third part i want to reduce the
model error and adjust otherwise i have
overfitting
and so far the super three dynamical
system i show up having a single
attractor
but if it has multiple attractors it
means the markov matrix will have
several it was a dominant dimension of
eigen function eigen dimension it's not
going to be one it's going to be several
so how to deal with those situations and
then finally
what i mentioned basically is one
universe from an ode and one universe in
pde i see there's some connections and
they motivate me to do it from one way
to the other but it's important to know
when i can do it and when i cannot and
those connections is also needed further
analysis
so thank you very much for your
attention and i would like to thank
especially uh adam obermann who ex uh
making this collaboration
uh feasible and also the fact that uh
ipam was the platform for us to meet
together well my collaborator i never
seen cd
thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you very much for sharing these
nice ideas
maybe you have time for a very small
question
i guess you were first nicolas
let me bring you the microphone
i hope not to disappoint with the
question so
um
so uh here you're assuming that you
observe the full uh uh estate um what
happens if you you know if you just have
an uh an observation of that
um
and maybe how would that be connected to
maybe these methods that people use like
to analyze dynamical systems kind of
like from this geometric perspective
like using these delay maps and uh
tekkens embedding and stuff like i mean
yeah yeah that's that's true if we don't
have a lot of data to be able to be a
good approximation to the environment
that will contribute to my model
discrepancy which means my continuity
equation model is not the perfect model
for that data so that is definitely is a
one problem and i think the nice thing
is here we don't require equally spaced
time trajectory it can just be randomly
sampled as long as you sample long
enough then we can have a occupation
manager so that's one flexibility
because um for example in order to
estimate the time derivative you need to
have a high quality but here and you can
also have noise because noise cancel
each other out when you add them all
together so there are some flexibility
but it's in order to have a
accurate approximation to the
environment it needs to be
long enough to some extent
all right i'll try to keep it short uh
thanks john for this very interesting
talk i have a question so um in
classical inverse problems you're
typically um facing a compact linear
forward operator which is has a
smoothing effect like a convolution
operator for instance and then since the
eigenvalues of this operator go to zero
you cannot invert it and you have to
regularize especially when your data is
not in the range of the operator right
but it seems like um in these problems
that you're looking at is actually the
other way around you have these
hyperbolic pde problems or these chaotic
ode systems where actually the forward
map is extremely chaotic and so you
would expect that the inverse map is
already regularizing or a smoothing map
um and so you made this point that the
vasterstein distance is a good choice
because somehow
robots with respect to noise but it
could be that it's just a general
property of the inverse problems that
you're looking at that they are robust
with respect to noise because they are
the inverse map is a smoothing operator
yeah that's that could be very likely i
think based on a lot of empirical
observation using this continuity
modeling you are regularizing the
problem the reconstruction as you can
see is a lot of the time are pretty
smooth
so that well unless it has to be pretty
smooth to work so there is the implicit
regulation about using marshes and
distance additionally maybe more like
the complexity part since it's
non-linear universe problem
okay thank you so much
so maybe yangxing i guess had something
to ask
no
oh we have time yes yes okay
i'm gonna be nice okay thanks uh
so i have a question about the
boundary conditions so here just by uh
you're trying to get the environment
distribution so you just construct this
m theta and you assume automatically
it's a
it's a markov matrix right
so
do you just say create artificial box uh
yeah okay the box and the enforce zero
no
flux condition yes so
you just use a cubix box oh yes keyboard
yeah i mean if you just impose this zero
flux condition can you just make it
because i picture that
your data is going to concentrate on i
mean especially for this example it's on
two-dimensional law yes right yeah is
there any way to just really create a
box it's not a regular box but you just
say
oh yeah not a regular box yes yeah just
uh just cover this bench then you use a
zero flux condition this may reduce the
computational capacity
quite a bit yeah that's actually a
potential uh direction because right now
i'm wasting a lot of blocks i'm wasting
a lot of space so that that is one way
but then it is i think it's become the
final volume discretization on a very
irregular geometry yeah but that will
save a lot of computational capacity
okay yes okay thanks
okay let's thank again yunnan
thank you very much